ich habe auf dem Kanal schon einige
Videos gemacht wo ich versucht habe
irgendwie Kohle zu verdienen mit
irgendwas entweder wo ich Videoschnitt
angeboten habe und echt richtig viel
Geld verdient habe 800 € im Monat
ja 800 € sind wie viel Geld
okay also dafür dass es der erste Monat
in der Selbständigkeit auf halber war es
echt viel Geld dann habe ich Umfragen
gemacht und dabei Geld verdient Gaming
habe ich gemacht bezahltes Gaming ja
tatsächlich Online Pokern wobei ich
Action Geld verdient habe und Daytrading
Aktien da habe ich überhaupt kein Geld
verdienen sondern sehr viel verloren wir
wollen essen machen und zwar auf Etsy
also es ist halt quasi wie ebay nur dass
man halt nur handgemachte Sachen
verkaufen
Kunst kann man da kaufen hier so ein
süßes Faultier ja aber du kannst halt
auch einfach so selbst designte
Klamotten kaufen kann
jetzt auch was raussuchen was wir fahren
einfach verkaufen können und ja also
wichtig ist dass es halt wenig Arbeit
ist und viel Geld bringt dieses Video
wird unterstützt von den Cookie mehr
dazu später und da beginnt jetzt die
Recherche was wir machen was können wir
überhaupt Personen bestimmt nicht ja ich
meine nahe liegen dass das hier
irgendwas mit Holz oder Metall oder so
machen was geil war alles mit Epoxidharz
ne also das war schon mal gemacht haben
war die Erfahrung für uns
da kann viel schief gehen ist auch viel
Arbeit lass einfach mal Holz Handarbeit
einfach suchen also es gibt sehr viel
Schneidebretter mit Epoxy aber es gibt
auch sehr viel ohne kunsthasen das ist
ziemlich einfach umzusetzen auch gängig
ist so eine Schrift die halbe Zutat ist
immer Liebe oh das ist doch was was war
relativ leicht machen können nochmals
das Holz Untersetzer woah Kork
Untersetzer sind wirklich
günstige Motive dann schon zu
Untersetzer wo du die Weltkugel reingeht
hast wieso Globus gibt's was
das hier so ausprobiert aber wie würdest
du das machen wir könnten zehn zehn und
damit die Proxy oder so Gießen boah
abox hier Alter das war deine Idee ja
ich weiß ich weiß auch nicht warum und
los geht's zuerst habe ich eine
Weltkugel auf einen dreidimensionalen
Globus projiziert dann suche ich mir
darauf eine schöne Perspektive für
unsere Untersetzer und Bretter ziemlich
eurozentristisch aber ich will natürlich
auch dass unsere deutschen Kunden auch
direkt erkennen warum sie es handelt und
fahren den Kontinent Afrika erkenn auch
super schnell nachdem ich die Erde von
einer Kugel dann wieder in eine Scheibe
verwandelt habt habe ich übrigens
deshalb gemacht damit das so gewölbt und
drei Dimensionen aussieht hinterher
glaube ich wäre es aber sogar besser
gewesen einfach direkt die
zweidimensionale Karte zu nehmen dann
wäre es auch nicht so komisch verzehrt
gewesen genau danach lasse ich im
CAD-Modell noch ein paar Inseln
verschwinden die so klein sind dass wir
unsere CNC Fräse sowieso nicht machen
könnte und macht daraus dann eben die
Vertiefung fürs Epoxidharz das
produzieren wir einfach in Massen das
geht weg wie sonst was ich Schwester
Logo für
King Store und ja let's go boah nee die
sind halt richtig schrecklich aus ne
findest du nee der letzte Situation
[Musik]
auf Basis von diesen Dingen hier
genau
minimalistische überlegt aber es war ein
bisschen schwierig
ausgespuckt das macht überhaupt keinen
Sinn aber der Name ist noch nicht
vergeben und es klingt irgendwie
schwedisch oder norwegisch und die Leute
denken bestimmt das ist heftig das ist
let's go da aber wirklich keiner
interessant wann Schneideblätter und
Untersetzer blind kaufen wird müssen wir
erstmal ein paar beispielprodukte
herstellen mit dem wir später dann
Beispiel Produktfotos machen können
[Musik]
Pascal das war der falsche Gang Auto
steht da hinten Pascal und ich war jetzt
gerade im Baumarkt und haben hier Holz
besorgt und daraus werden wir jetzt
erstmal jeweils vier schweinebretter
machen
warum drauf
erstmals richtiges Sägeblatt drauf
[Musik]
und schneiden uns mal die ersten
also ich habe jetzt eine Tischkreissäge
einfach der Länge nach halbiert und die
schneiden wir jetzt einfach noch mal in
der Mitte durch und dann sind die
Schneidebrett auch schon so fertig
so schnell und einfach hat man was was
aussieht wie schneidet das machen wir
hier noch so schöne Rundungen hin mit
unserer Oberfräse das ist hier auch noch
schön anzufassen ist nicht so
[Musik]
nur noch ein bisschen geschliffen und
dann sind die auch schon so gut wie
fertig
ich habe die Bretter jetzt auf jeden
Fall geschliffen bis 320er Körnung jetzt
habe ich gelesen dass man da noch mal
Wasser drauf sprühen soll das ist so
diese ganzen feinen Härchen noch mal
aufstellen sieht man auch schon ein
bisschen wie die Bretter hinterher geölt
ausschauen werden richtig gut richtig
gut das ist richtig krass jetzt nachdem
ich da Wasser drauf gesprüht hat ist es
komplett drauf aber Schleifen mit 320
und dann sollte das passen soll ich
jetzt alle Bretter noch mal schön
abgeschliffen die sind jetzt richtig
richtig gut jetzt geht's da drüber man
Laser den hat Pascal schon aufgebaut
unter Lasern wird dann noch unser Logo
und diese ganzen personalisierten Namen
oder sprich je nachdem was die Leute da
drauf haben wollen
lesen wir dann da drauf habe ich immer
drauf Automat drauf
zum Laser
macht genau was soll oder oder
[Musik]
Werbung einfach
richtig pervers gut
die Bretter sind soweit fertig fehlen
nur noch die Produktfotos für unseren
Shop die machen wir noch schnell in
unserem provisorischen Fotostudio
mal schauen ob jetzt Kunden Anbeißen auf
meine Reichweite verzichten wir
natürlich komplett um zu sehen ob das
einmal wirklich jeder machen kann oder
nicht später werden wir noch auf Etsy
selbst Werbung schalten da kann man zum
Beispiel ein oder zwei oder zehn oder
100 Euro am Tag ausgeben damit seiner
Titel Leuten vorgeschlagen wird aber
zuerst schauen wir ob es auch ohne geht
weniger ins Auto auf und ich habe keine
notification gekriegt das einfach das
erste Teil schon verkauft wurde und das
ging ja instant also manu hat heute
fertig gemacht vorher wahrscheinlich
drei Stunden oder vier und schon aber
der erste Sekunde übel geil ich hätte
niemals gedacht dass es so schnell geht
für sein Schneidebrett hat unser erster
Kunde auch direkt eine Personalisierung
bestellt die unser sandwand laservice
also Pascal direkt umsetzt nachdem die
dadurch entstandenen Schmauchspuren
weggeschliffen sind und das Brett geölt
ist wird die Ware sicher verpackt und ab
die Post um irgendwas online zu kaufen
oder zu verkaufen kommt man nicht
drumherum seine persönlichen Daten preis
zu geben sogenannte data Broker machen
mit dem Verkauf eurer Daten richtig
Arsch und plötzlich haben am Ende eure
Handynummer E-Mail vollen Namen wissen
wo er wohnt sogar wann er geboren seid
und Spam euch dann mit Werbung zu oder
der data Broker hat sogar an datenlack
und eure Daten sind plötzlich einfach
öffentlich und das ist mir tatsächlich
auch schon passiert der einzige Weg um
seine Daten richtig zu schützen ist es
jedem einzelnen dieser data Broker zu
schreiben dass er aufhören soll deine
Daten zu nutzen aber davon gibt's
hunderte und überall muss man irgendwie
ein anderes Formular ausfüllen und das
würde Monate dauern also macht keiner
außer incognit der Sponser des heutigen
Videos die machen genau das für euch und
finden heraus wer diese data Broker sind
und kontaktieren Sie für euch und machen
diesen ganzen Formular und Papierkram
alles was ihr dafür machen müsst ist
euch ein Account anzulegen und
zuzustimmen dass in KODi für euch diese
data Broker kontaktieren darf ab dann
könnt ihr eure Füße hochlegen und
inkognitive Arbeit machen lassen ihr
seht dann hier in so einer Übersicht
wieder stand bei den einzelnen da der
Brocken ist die eure Daten haben und
wenn dann wieder mal irgendeiner davon
weg hat sind eure Daten nicht mehr dabei
die ersten 100 die den Code tomorro über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung
eingeben bekommen 60% Rabatt auf ihn
also schaut doch mal vorbei wir wollen
aber nicht nur die klassischen
Schneidebretter anbieten sondern auch
die Runde Weltkugel mit edlem Epoxy in
Lady wir vorhin schon designt haben das
kann die CNC präziser als in jeder
Mensch und dadurch wird auch jede
Bestellung genau gleich wie die andere
[Musik]
okay
hallo wir würden gerne unseren 60
Mitarbeitern zu Weihnachten möglichst
mit dem Text 70 Jahre
wir machen kein Youtuber
das sind 700 € 6
[Musik]
drauf
gekauft genau
dann würde ich jetzt mal vorschlagen wir
skribbeln mal so den Lasertag und dann
schick mir einfach zwei Proben zu und
schauen ob wir das gut für den anderen
ja null theoretisch pass auf gar keine
Arbeit wir haben Muster in 40 auf 30
aber 10 cm ja ich würde sagen Pascal der
hier im Büro Alter ist von unserem
Unterfangen hier muss noch mal den Preis
ändern weil wir sind jetzt erstmal eine
Woche beschäftigt wir sind aktuell bei
9,99 und wir machen aktuell pro Brett 4
€ Verlust
wenn man seine Arbeit zwar noch nicht
mit heimfiziert
Smart dann Manu Chester Schreinerei
Abteilung du machst die Muster dass wir
die rausschicken können
Konzeption was ich eigentlich machen
würde ist ja gerade aktuell ein bisschen
auf und holt weil diese Weltkugel
Schneidebretter und Untersetzer
überzeugt bin ich stehen jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen hinten an weil wir einfach
ausgebucht sind
eine von euch gedacht dass wir so einen
Auftrag kriegen ich habe dreimal gesagt
das war 12 € machen und du hast auf die
Idee gekommen
die Muster für unseren Großauftrag sind
verpackt und gehen jetzt ab zur Post so
die Weltkugel in der zehn Maschine ist
erstmal grob fertig sieht ziemlich geil
aus muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich will
jetzt folgendes im Schilde wir machen
jetzt ein Ozean der muss blau sein
deswegen haben wir hier Epoxidharz hier
schön blaue Farbe und da mische ich mir
jetzt was zusammen ich hoffe dass die
Menge hier reicht wenn nicht ich merke
mir auf jeden Fall das Verhältnis ja und
vielleicht eine Brille drauf anziehen so
ich kippe jetzt einfach mal bisschen
rein ich glaube wir hätten es eins zu
eins das ist ziemlich CC dann Farbe
Sherry Bluse sieht eigentlich ganz geil
aus oder skyblue ich jetzt die Tropfen
nehmen Sie die ganze Zahlen sehr schön
25 Gramm okay passt genau bisschen weiße
Farbe damit es nicht so transparent ist
sondern ein bisschen milchiger oder
geht's
mega geile Farbe kann man überhaupt
nichts anderes sagen okay der Moment der
Wahrheit ich gebe das jetzt einmal rein
geil okay mega krass aus
[Musik]
jetzt nicht ganz so liebevoll sein
Kipp einmal rein
bisschen grüße ich jetzt das in der CNC
zu machen aber man muss jetzt mit dem
Feuer drüber gehen damit die
Luftbläschen weggehen
[Musik]
ein Tag später ist ein Epoxidharz
getrocknet jetzt richten wir es nur noch
ab dass wir eine schön glatte Oberfläche
haben und das machen wir mit diesen
richtigen Winden Fräser
[Musik]
jetzt die Arbeit für mich macht mal
einen Kaffee
ach du heiliger was denn hier passiert
also ich würde sagen das hat man den
großen Brettern schon mal ganz gut
funktioniert
[Musik]
so die CNC sitzt fertig und abrichten
jetzt Fräsen wir die Dinger noch einmal
rund aus und dann geht's an schleifen
und Öl
[Musik]
ich habe die Dinge jetzt eigentlich die
ganze Zeit mit der Hand geschliffen
damit seine Vorrichtung ausgefrierst
einfach reinlegen drauf
das geht einfach zehnmal schneller
[Musik]
und genau wie für die einfachen
Schneidebretter haben wir auch für die
Schneidebretter und Untersetzer im
weltkugeldesign die etc-anträge gemacht
und dann gewartet und gewartet und
gewartet aber keiner hat gekauft beim
einfachen Schneidebrett ist leider auch
bei der einen Bestellung geblieben seit
mehreren Tagen kam dort nichts und auf
die Antwort ob die Firma der wir die
Muster zugeschickt haben und nun den
Auftrag für die 60 Bretter gibt oder
nicht auf die wart mir auch noch drum
schalte jetzt mal Werbung bei Ärzte geht
das super easy dann wird dir das auch am
weinen jeder Stelle vorgeschlagen und
als erstes machen wir mal Werbung für
2,50 € pro Tag und schon mal was
passiert so aber jetzt lief immer noch
überhaupt gar nichts die steht jetzt
aber drei Käufer haben deine Ticket in
den letzten 90 Tagen im warenkopf lassen
und da kann man jetzt quasi bewerben
dass die noch mal das Zeug sehen und das
machen wir jetzt auch man kann hier
generell auch auf Marketing gehen und
sich bei search Analytics anschauen über
welche Suchanfragen die Leute unserer
Artikel finden ihr Platz an sie
Schneidebrett Platz zwei Schneidebretter
noch mal schnell was Holz also
hauptsächlich so Schneidebrett halt ganz
einfach und dann irgendwann kommt
einfach stecke was ist das was ist ein
Steckel keine Ahnung wenn ihr das wisst
was ein Stecker ist schreibt das mal in
die Kommentare na ja und weil bei 2,50 €
Budget pro Tag einfach gar nicht gesehen
das haben wir jetzt einfach mal 10 € pro
Tag drauf übrigens fun fact ich glaube
mehr als 25 € pro Tag kann man gar nicht
ausgeben ich glaube das macht ja nicht
wollen dass ich eine große Firma
herkommen und einfach Tausende von Euro
oder jeden Falle eigentlich ziemlich
nice wieder was passiert 20 Tage nachdem
wir unseren ersten Artikel eingestellt
haben
und wir schauen heute zum letzten mal
rein und das ist immer noch keine neue
Bestellung ja abgeschlossen eins mehr
kam nicht die ganze Zeit nicht trotz
Werbung also das Geld Alter Weg okay das
heißt wir mit der Kampagne 3000 €
gekriegt 47 Klicks aber von 0
Bestellungen so wir haben insgesamt 19
Dollar und 11 Cent dafür ausgegeben für
Werbung bekommt er nochmal zurück
genauen Kostenanalyse wie viel das jetzt
gekostet hat ja weil die Einnahmen die
sind natürlich relativ überschaubar der
Umsatz war nämlich bei 9,99 € hier sind
übrigens wieder wie das Interesse an
unseren Artikeln im zeitlichen Verlauf
war das beliebteste waren
ultra günstig war ich habe auch eine
Nachricht und die Nachricht ist von
diesem Wohnungsbau Ludwigsburg
dass wir der Logo quasi hier mit in
diesem Video zeigen auf jeden Fall
heftig so eine Anfrage von so einem fast
städtischen Betrieb gekriegt haben wenn
natürlich auch krasser gewesen hätten 60
Bretter auch tatsächlich produziert die
beiden Bretter die wir sehen schon
geschickt haben als Muster das werden
die an der Weihnachtsfeier aber verlosen
eine Mitarbeiter wir haben gesagt dass
wir uns das nicht zurückschicken müssen
hier sehen wir gerade noch mal unsere
Artikel Einträge sind ziemlich coole
Produkte die ich finde auch in echt ja
also das hier ist mega geil ich
persönlich hätte da echt erwartet dass
er mehr gehen würde
oder so denke ich dass das ganz gut
gehen würde ja ich glaube das ist ein
Gewinner Produkt ist
also da kann man nichts falsch machen
wir gehen jetzt mal rein in die Bücher
wie viel hat das ganze gekostet mit den
ganzen Material das wir gekauft haben
und wie verhält sich das im Vergleich zu
den 9,99 € Umsatz die wir gemacht haben
man hat immer so eine kleine Übersicht
gemacht wir fangen jetzt erstmal den
Schneidebrettern an also dem hier und da
haben wir allein für das Holz 8,75 €
ausgegeben super teuer also man hätte
natürlich dann auch super viel Geld
sparen können hätte man es nicht im
Baumarkt gekauft so wie wir aber es war
jetzt einfach das leichteste auf die
Zeit und dann Öl für sich sein
Verbrauchsgüter ein bisschen Strom
Gehalt so ein Tischler verdient
irgendwie bis zu 16 € pro Stunde hat
Nummer 4 € drauf gemacht weil der
Arbeitgeber Krankenversicherung und
alles mögliche oben drauf Zahl
20 € pro Stunde das ist natürlich jetzt
nicht der Stundenlohn wieder von Manu
noch von mir Versand doch einfach 5 € 94
also ich bin mir sicher es hat noch
irgendwie taktisch besser machen können
wenn man irgendwie größere Mengen hat
oder so aber das ist die Realität für
uns gewesen 5,49 € und damit ist es
quasi viel teurer gewesen das Ding zu
produzieren also es ist angeboten hatten
das resultiert darin das ist 21:55
kostet hätte das zu machen für uns man
findet solche Bretter auch irgendwie
eher für So 15 in den 19 25 Euro im
Internet genau das heißt wir haben auf
dieses eine Brett runtergerechnet 11,56
€ plus gemacht bei den weltbrettern ja
da sind noch mal ein gutes Stück anders
aus da hätten wir die für 38 €
produzieren können und selbst das hätte
man noch gut optimieren können und ein
Verkaufspreis von 90 € ist für solche
großen Bretter auf jeden Fall
realistisch sondern hätten uns
vielleicht auch für 70 verkaufen können
und da wir auf jeden Fall Gewinn drin
gewesen aber leider wollte keiner wir
haben uns natürlich für das Video hier
auf eine größere Auftragslage
vorbereitet deswegen haben wir für 400 €
gekauft und naja dieser
unternehmensversuch hat uns deswegen
jetzt hier fiktiv 1350 € kostet aber ein
effektiv weil es kam jetzt in echt nicht
so rechnen erstens mit dem echten halt
erstmal höher und das Material hier das
ist natürlich nicht verloren das benutzt
man einfach für die nächsten Videos und
die sieht ja wenn ihr den Kanal
abonniert und wenn ihr schon mal beim
Abo Button sein da ist die
Videobeschreibung auch nicht weiß da
findet ihr nämlich den Link zu gucken
wenn ihr eure persönlichen Daten besser
schützen wollt und ich wollte das
plötzlich irgendjemand eurer Adresse
oder sonst was hat und ich würde sagen
das was von diesem Video